حيث قالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان شابا
فلسطينيا استشهد برصاصه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي صباحا اليوم في مدينه الخليل
بالضفه الغربيه واضافت الوزاره في بيان
النشاب نسيم ابو فوده استشهد متاثرا
باصابته برصاصه في الراس اطلقها عليه جنود
الاحتلال في مدينه الخليل بينما افادتنا
صدره الفلسطينيه بان القوات من جيش
الاحتلال فتحت نيران اسلحتها تجاه الشاب
بينما كان يقود مركبته باتجاه احد الحواجز
العسكريه الاسرائيليه قرب الحرم
الابراهيمي وسط المدينه
في هذه الاثناء اعتدت مجموعه من
المستوطنين على مواطنين فلسطينيين في قريه
جالوت جنوب نابلس بالضفه الغربيه وهو ما
ادى لاصابه فلسطينيين ذكر شهود عيان ان
المستوطنين هاجموا منازل في القريه
واحرقوا مركبه على الاقل هجمت مجموعه اخرى
بالحجاره مركبات فلسطينيه عند مدخل القريه
من القدس
وجرافات تهدم البيوت
ومتطرفون يعتدون على الفلسطينيين والتصعيد
مستمر
بالفعل التصعيد مستمر ومتواصل من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قبل قليل تم الاعلان
عن استشهاد الشاب من مدينه الخليل نسيم
ابو فودي ويبلغ من العمر 26 عاما قد اصيب
صباح اليوم برصاص مباشر من قبل قوات
الاحتلال عند احد الحواجز العسكريه في
مدينه الخليل وهي تؤدي الى الحرم
الابراهيمي في وسط المدينه بحسب الروايه
الفلسطينيه طلب منه ايه جنود الاحتلال
التوقف لكن يبدو بانه لم يدرك هذا الطلب
فاقامه مباشره باطلاق النار عليه في عمليه
اعدام اخرى لفلسطيني اخر في مدينه الخليل
كما هو معروف مدينه الخليل بها العديد من
الحواجز العسكريه التابعه لقوات الاحتلال
وهذا احد قال الحواجز المنطقه الجنوبيه
يطلق عليه حاجز رقم 160 وهو قريب جدا من
حاجز عسكري اخر هو حاجز ابو الريش وفي بعض
الاحيان لا ينتبه ربما الفلسطينيون لي ايه
لما لتعليمات جنود الاحتلال عندما يطلب
منهم التوقف او ما الى ذلك مباشره تم
اطلاق النار عليه وهذا ما حصل ليصبح عدد
الشهداء الفلسطينيين في اقل من شهر منذ
بدايه هذا العام 35 شهيدا فلسطينيه
قبل ايام عده بالاضافه الى ذلك يتعرض
الفلسطينيون منذ عده ايام الى تصعيد في
اعتداءات المستوطنين في مناطق متفرقه في
الضفه الغربيه تحديدا في قريه نص ساعه عيه
غربه رام الله وايضا في قريه جالوت جنوب
نابلس حيث يتم احراق السيارات والمركبات
الخاصه بالمواطنين الفلسطينيين وايضا
القاء الحجاره طيله الوقت والاعتداء على
الفلسطينيين وعلى ممتلكاتهم هذا بالاضافه
الى عده مسيرات استفزازيه يقوم بها
المستوطنين منذ عمليه همم مستوطنه يعقوب
ايضا في القدس المحتله في سلوان كان هناك
يوم امس مسيره استفزازيه للمستوطنين
بحمايه قوات الاحتلال هذا بالاضافه الى
تواجدهم ووصوله وقت حماتهم المتواصله الى
المسجد الاقصى المبارك في منطقه جبل
المكبر وفي عده احياء اخرى في القدس
المحتله وصلت صباح هذا اليوم جرافات تابعه
لبلديه الاحتلال تم هدم سور استنادي لاحد
المنازل قيد الانشاء هذا ليوم قبل حتى ان
يتم بناء هذا المنزل وصلت جرافات الاحتلال
صباح هذا اليوم في حي السواحري في بلده
جبل المكبر وهدمت اساسات هذا المنزل هذا
بالاضافه الى الهدم الذي شاهدناه يوم امس
لمنزل عائله مطر
وايضا في منا- واغلاق منزل منفذ عمليه
مستوطنه في القدس اغلاق المنزل بالكامل
وتشريد العائله وايضا القرار الذي اتخذ
بخصوص شكرا اغلاق منزل الفتى محمد عليوات
في بلده سلوان مباشره في جلسه الحكومه
التي عقدت الليله الماضيه هذا يندرج
الرسميه اتخذها المجلس الوزاري الاسرائيلي
الامن المصغر ومن الواضح ان هذه الحكومه
تتجه الى مزيد من التصعيد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه نجوان السمري من القدس شكرا
جزيلا